nights like these that that tell me I'm
old
I've been around a while been doing this
a bit yeah I mean like I can't stand
night shoots anymore
um I'll gladly hand a stunt over to a
stunt man I no longer remember the first
rule of Fight Club
I'm going to give my friend Fincher a
pass as well and and just say I I love
that man dearly he's changed my life
he's he's the master he's a master
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know what you're right I just
read that the Scorsese and De Niro are
on their 10th film so if we are half as
good as they are we should at least do
five
also in nights like this where I feel so
fortunate to all the amazing people I've
been able to work with has meant so much
to me thank you for seeing the films
thank you for being film lovers
thank you